iker si on le sait il s'est suicidé le
30 avril
s'ils s'étaient arrêtées après munich
comme l'espérait chamberlain après tout
à munich c'est sa dernière revendication
c'est les allemands des sudètes une
partie de la tchécoslovaquie
imaginons qu'ils s'arrêtent là on est le
30 septembre 1938
on est quelques jours avant la nuit de
cristal il n'y a pas encore eu la nuit
de cristal qui était une date très
importante qui va qui va jouer dans le
dans le détestation que le régime nazi
va inspirer notamment aux anglais
messi s'était arrêté à munich est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
l'allemagne ne s'en souviendraient pas
comme comme un grand homme d'état après
tout serait était l'homme qui avait
reconstitué l'allemagne après traité
versailles sans tirer un seul coup de
fusil est ce qu'on voit là c'était quand
même une sacrée prouesse il aurait été
le plus grand homme d'état de toute
l'histoire allemande plus grande
bismarck car il aurait achevé leur de
bismarck et à la différence de bismarck
qui a fait trois guerres pour assurer
l'unification allemande
il n'en aurait mené aucune pour arriver
à ses fins seulement la manoeuvre le
chantage l'intimidation le mensonge
péché véniel quand on pense à la suite
auray auraient été ses armes
oui je pense qu'ils auraient vu s'il
avait fait un arrêt cardiaque en octobre
aujourd'hui on le sait les breurey
probablement comme le plus grand homme
d'état allemand avait quand même des
petits bémols on dirait sans doute que
on ne savait pas vraiment comment
fonctionnait le reich il y avait eu les
camps de concentration mais là aussi il
y avait encore rien de rien de massif
mais il aurait quand même remarquer
qu'il avait transformée
la vieille tradition étatique allemande
en main en un tas de ruines que
l'économie allemande allait très mal en
réalité tout ça ce serait apparu mais je
pense que encore une fois oui il aurait
été le plus grand le plus gros pot de
l'histoire allemande au lieu de vie
avant de devenir
il est aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
repoussoir absolu pour les générations
dans le monde après la guerre en
espérant que ça reste comme ça
[Musique]